this is a production of cornell
university
it's a huge pleasure and honor for me to
welcome fred ratundi as our
second speaker of the series so it was
gonna be evan fred
for this title slide that were that's on
our screens now
unfortunately eva is sick in bed and so
uh
fred illustrating one of the many um
positive features of a teamwork approach
to science fred is here and gonna give
the
talk uh so fred a huge thanks for um
being with us and that best wishes to
eva for um
you know feeling much better soon so um
let me introduce
the two of them starting with our
speaker fred and i just want to say
at the outset here that um back in 2015
the pair of them received a tremendous
honor of the us von liebig award for
world nutrition so it was a
huge uh honor from the german uh
government and um or maybe i'm wrong
that it's a government but but a huge
huge honor there recognizing lifetime
achievement
for this very distinguished pair and
they'd also received the king bowdoin
award for pearl millet breeding in the
past so
um extremely um accomplished
pair of breeders for dryland cereals so
uh
starting with fred um fred um
is from wisconsin and the the two of
them are
still associated or now have been since
2016 associated with the university of
wisconsin where
fred's from and one of their daughters
is
currently uh there in wisconsin and the
others there with them
uh the fred and never currently in
germany where it was from
so uh fred got his master's in phd from
iowa state
back in the 80s and then um got a he'd
gotten his bachelor's at university of
wisconsin
uh then he did a dairy internship peace
corps
in ecuador um worked at the university
of iowa in 80 early 80s an oat breeding
then in the mid 80s started working on
pearl miller breeding with icarusa in
india
the international center for research on
this emory tropics
uh and then did a postdoc back in
hohnheim in germany
working on rye breeding and then since
the
early 90s have been back with the inter
international research
uh center for research in the summer air
tropics echo said
first for some years in india working in
rajasthan
and then for almost 20 years working as
principal scientists
on sorghum breeding and genetic
resources um
so evan sort of they've both been
wisconsin germany um
india west africa of course ever got her
started
um in hohnheim with her degrees
but she actually did her did her high
school years in beirut lebanon which i
had not been
aware of so and she also had us
with the technical university of munich
in the 80s
which was in collaboration with icarda
one of the other uh
area international centers i've also
played key roles in the drylands
collaborative research
program of the cg of recent years
and they both bring i think for this
seminar i'm really pleased that it's two
aspects that i hope will interest
everybody a lot which is uh well
reading for the dryland cereals and with
climate issues and stresses
ramping up i think there are insights on
breeding for difficult
and heterogeneous environments will be
very important
in addition the idea of participatory
research engaging
farmers themselves in the research
process sometimes at impressive scales
and then thirdly but i'm sure not lastly
the idea of how to work with farmers on
seed systems getting the
the products of the breeding process
into the hands of more farmers
um in a way that is fully respects their
roles as decision makers and and and
actors in that process so
i think these are some of these things
are areas where we we as a department
or sorry now a section don't have as
much
formal training for our students and so
i'm just really appreciative i really
appreciate fred
you're sharing your insights and
experience with us i know there's a lot
of demand around agricultural
thinking and reading not just from the
students also from the whole whole
faculty as well
um not for this participatory and
stress-related reading so
um over to you fred with tremendous
thanks and best wishes
to eva so i'm just feeling yes
thank you very much rebecca and
we'll just start right in with
our talk which really was
representing trying to distill our
experiences and contributions from so
many partners
throughout the years regarding sorghum
improvement in west africa
and first just a few pictures just to
get
an impression of sorghum here in
mali in the field harvesting
uh the braided bundles of
panicles of selected
panicles that farmers are going to be
keeping
[Music]
for using as seed and
[Music]
where sorghum is grown across west and
central africa
across a wide band as you can see
stretching from
senegal and the far west across to sudan
and conforming to
the rainfall iso heights that are
actually very narrow bands stretching
east to west and sorghum
being a staple crop
in a very broad area
involving many if you will different
uh agro ecosystems ranging from about
100
days of growing period to 200 days
of growing period based on the lengths
of rainfall in the
single rainy season per year you any
modal rainfall
another aspect of
importance for sorghum production in
west africa is
that the soils are very old highly
weathered
and available plant available phosphorus
is very low
as you can see here where
the level for sufficiency threshold is
about
10 parts per million and
you can see how much of west africa is
colored yellow which is five
or less parts per million
and that translates
here into experiences for
many people individuals here we have
a sample of 90 farmers fields
who were participating in sorghum
variety testing
men and women equal numbers
and you can see the majority of both are
below that sufficiency threshold
but particularly women which
actually would be expected
when their system of
rotation is understood and that
typically women
are assigned the fields
for their use when the fertility has
dropped
so low that the men who are responsible
for producing the staple cereals like
sorghum pearl millet corn
it's no longer uh productive
and the women who very often are growing
uh peanuts for the sauce then
are having the lowest fertility
available
so with this short background for
sorghum
production in west africa we
in the big sense uh
both even myself as breeders with
ecosatch
in an international ag research center
as well as the national
program breeders are faced with several
dilemmas
for improving sorghum the first is what
germplasm-based to use for breeding
and then how to design an effective
selection strategy
that meets the diversity complexity of
the conditions
how to get seed of those new varieties
of farmers
and what does it mean to breed
for achieving development goals
these dilemmas will provide the
structure
for what i will share and
hopefully we can discuss about later
first of all the germplasm base sorghum
can be classified into five major races
based on the grain shape
and the gloom uh
shape morphological characteristics
which interestingly enough match
very closely with what is found when
doing
molecular marker diversity studies
genetic studies
and this is a very beautiful study
which cornell has been a big part of
for sorghum uh with
analysis using g was
of
nearly a thousand sorghum accessions
these are
germplasm gene bank accessions
and with this we can see how
those major races really divide up
from the map of africa and the
distribution of those races we can see
that
the quad datum race in blue
is really important in eastern and
southern africa
and that is the race that has been used
most widely in
international breeding worldwide
from india to the us australia
the guinea race the tan color
is actually distributed worldwide
and is one of the most it is actually
based on molecular studies
the most diverse of the races
uh west africa uh
has predominantly and almost only
uh the guinea race with a little bit of
dura actually in
the drier sahel region
it's also interesting while we're on
this just to note how
for the sorghums in far west africa that
would be
from senegal through mali to burkina
faso
separate from those
i'm sorry i did it's actually far west
would be those and
separate from those of the more humid
areas nigeria and cameroon
and that actually has we think
uh gives some useful insights for hybrid
breeding
but we can maybe touch on that later
so the germplasm options for breeding
sorghum basically are
two one is to use a land race germplasm
which is widely grown by farmers is
considered
to be rustic meaning
low yield grain yield
but very resilient
very tall average three meters
four meters we had trials uh even
five meter height average
uh photoperiod sensitive uh
but there's been very little formal
breeding
done in this race unless no elite
materials are available
the second option would be to use the
improved germplasm developed through
international breeding efforts
which is short height and
almost uh entirely insensitive to photo
period
and is predominantly caudate and based
and the photos
that upper two are of uh guinea
pinnacles
as you can see uh very different from
here from mali uh caudata material
more compact medical and if you can see
within a sufficient resolution of the
photos
here considerable grain mold is also
because of the compact pentacles
feeding of head bugs
with nice protection in those compact
pentacles
so uh so there are many traits
that need to be considered for certain
breeding
uh fortunately
if you will most of them only need to
meet a certain
threshold for acceptability we don't
have to improve all of them but
they have to be there but
grain yield really is imperative
it is one that needs improvement it's
identified by farmers
as being a top priority
stover quality is another trait that
really represents tremendous opportunity
as the local land race sorghums tall
extremely sturdy
woody and non-digestible for livestock
and with a crop livestock integration a
real opportunity
for improving stover quality
if we look at the two options that we
have laid out the
land race material basically guinea and
the improved
claudia materials we can see that for
most of those traits required for
adaptation for quality
they are present in the germ the
landry's germplasm which is
well material it evolved and was
selected
in that environment as compared to the
improved quad and materials
with the exception importantly of for
example stover quality
and specific resistances
so in short we
as a group have targeted uh work using
the guinea race
as a germplasm base with its very hard
grain
which is resistant to decortication
losses
which we'll come to later and
the blacks
loose panicle which has adaptation
advantages for adaptation and the photo
period sensitivity which is important
for
uh plasticity of matching the growth
duration
of the stone crop to the
available moisture and
achieving basically a the same
flowering maturity date irrespective of
whether it's sewn
in mid-june or end of july
and adaptation to various factors soil
fertility
uh excess of water as well as
insufficient water
with uh germplasm
of uh land race and improved land race
materials
we and predecessors have created
renomating populations uh
tall guinea land race from that uh
drive the dwarf guinea land race guinea
population also
uh one for low p adaptation
and also uh more narrow-based
populations with
back crossing diverse donors of
different
races including the guinea
to a guinea parent and then back
crossing once to the guinea
parent and from these different
populations we have
been able to obtain useful diversity for
example
with dwarf height which did not exist
prior in the land race materials was
combined
with stover quality
and these populations are
ideal for sharing with others with other
breeders
with also with farmers
who can select according to their
priorities and conditions
the second issue question is how to
design an effective selection strategy
with
increasing grain yield being a top
priority
but generally
there is i can say at most a single
research station per
agroecological zone
and the unstationed experiment station
conditions
are very different and poorly represent
the target conditions in the farmers
fields
which are also very diverse
with a broad complexity of
environmental factors and as we have
seen many traits
of importance for acceptance and
adaptation
and the difficulty for individuals
to be able to discriminate among
progenies or varieties for
really important traits like yield
food yield and for farmers for traits
requiring
more managed conditions for example
straggler resistance
and our
results from trying to address those
issues
through collaboration between breeders
and farmers we begin
here with a study on early generation
yield evaluation a real question as
we've
just mentioned with on station and on
firm conditions being so different and
wanting to maximize genetic gain for
farmer conditions so with 150 early
generation progenies
tested and selected both on farm
with subsets of 50 progenies per farmer
and on station with the whole set
together
in a three replicate alpha lattice
design
in two fields one with low phos plant
available phosphorus and one with high
and 12 progeny selected from each
with actually it turns out three being
in common
between those and those were tested over
two years
in farmer's fields and here we have the
yield of those progenies
platted against the trial means and
what's interesting is we have in black
the czechs
land race varieties and all of the
others are selected
we can see some progress over the land
race checks
the selections from on farm and on
station are
actually overlapping but the three that
were
selected from both on-farm and on
station
were very high so three cheers for
combining results
at the involvement of the breeders with
farmers in conducting on-farm
participatory variety trials
for yield became a major aspect of the
breeding programs
in mali and in the region
in these trials
we're testing 30 to 40
progenies varieties both on station as
well as on farm
and here this table
it shows the results
prepared with the names of the varieties
each column is a different farmer with
the yield given
in 100 kilo sacs a unit they can
identify with with in the local language
the mean yield and the repeatability
and color coded for above
the mean based on standard deviation
centered here mean and below
and the farmers would study these and
use these as well as of course the
breeders using this data
for making decisions on what to retain
what to
focus on for for example seed production
in the
following years etc here
trial results from those yield results
from those trials
here we have
in blue and red the local variety here
blue
the local variety and we see here
a very promising progeny that
shows superior yield across
the productivity range
to the local varieties
this was an open pollinated variety
and here we have two hybrids or actually
three hybrids and the locals and we can
see here
uh again with these trials we can
really see the performance across
productivity conditions which is a whole
mix of factors
with the open pollinated varieties we
had managed to make 10 15 percent gain
with the hybrids
we had 30 percent yield to priorities
uh the post-harvest
quality testing also became a
important part of the testing
series conducted
both for uh
taste consistency
quality of the food with taste testing
but also in the
preparation and processing of the grain
so the actions that
as a group were being taken were
testing and selecting in the target zone
thanks to many farmers at collaboration
testing in multiple environments
and under a range of conditions both
fertility and on station
with managed low phosphorus as well as
the
routine recommended
if you will uh fertility management
and linking breeding and crop management
and food preparation in
the mix of the breeding decision making
and farmers were
involved integrated into the
different stages of the breeding cycle
through these
trials through discussions
during the trials in the annual feedback
meetings
and planning meetings etc for setting
priorities
for generating diversity particularly
the random eating populations
uh in selections farmers
and breeders love to select but
especially farmers love to select
individual
plants spentacles to the evaluation and
to bridal release and dissemination
which we'll be talking about later
so there were really
a network of farmers and breeders
established variety testing
and selection
[Music]
which is presented here in this
map here with the experiment stations of
ecosatch and two of the national
program sorghum breeding program and the
farmer cooperatives
or unions of cooperatives that were
collaborating with the breeders
across southern valley
with a back drop of the rainfall iso
heights
uh the third question how to get seed of
these new varieties that are being bred
to the farmers
let's take an overview a snapshot from
the year 2000 where the national seed
service was largely dysfunctional
with the structural adjustments being in
full swing
and the extension services shrinking or
disappearing completely
there were no private sector seed
companies present
and farmers did not
purchase seed it was basically an
unknown
behavior
fortunately at that time variety
registration
in the national variety catalog was very
easy
uh the breeders could just develop a
description fish technique and it
sent it to the responsible person for
inclusion
as the breeder was responsible for
choosing and maintaining the seed
and seeded certification was possible
but expensive
steps that were taken in this
background for getting seed to
farmers of these new varieties there
were
detailed studies of the farmers
seed management system conducted
a farm organizations farmer clubs
that were involved they're interested in
grain marketing were identified
as uh likely having interest and demand
for new varieties
and collaborating farmers in the variety
testing activities
on their own decided to initiate
large-scale seed production
and through these various activities
there was joint learning by the farmer
organizations
and the various partners including ngos
radio breeders
and disseminating seed
we'll start with some results here from
a
study of the farmer seed system in one
village in mali
which uh it was found that there were 12
varieties
being grown in that village with one to
five varieties being grown
by each of the large extended families
corresponding to the different uses and
adaptation specificities of those
uh varieties and the conditions for the
available to the farmers uh
the source of those varieties were from
basically from the village or from the
family
and from the farmer's own production
we had several surprises one was that
although there were many varieties being
grown there are only one or
two varieties that were really
predominant that were covering about 80
of the area the major
varieties and that those varieties
were changing they were the ones that
were currently
predominant were very new they were less
than 10 years old
and these new and new varieties actually
rarely came from
formal sources from breed breeding
programs
also there was learning of
the social expectations and thinking
about
seed in obtaining seed in acceptable
ways
for example that a good farmer produces
his or her own seed that
taking seed from outside
at the time of sowing is not okay
but it really is a prestige
to be asked by someone to give them seed
but
taking money for that seed is not okay
and that the farmers
almost universally welcomed testing of
new varieties we're excited
and when i asked would you like small
trials looking at three to f
or five fridays or big trials generally
people always wanted the more we can see
the better
so through many years of
learning by doing basically and
discussing
uh we learned several things one that
the unfarm variety trials
actually didn't assure large-scale
awareness
or dissemination of new varieties one
thing we were
thinking might be piggybacked on the
testing program
however the farmers
interest and demand for receiving trial
sets
uh especially of the not the first stage
testing but the second stage farmer
entirely farmer managed only three to
five varieties
far outstripped the breeders capacity to
provide
uh with requests going up to 200
300 400
that the collaborating farmers
as i mentioned farmers
who were involved in the variety testing
on their own decided to start producing
seed
of those varieties as a really conscious
decision to address the issue of
disseminating seed of
the newly developed varieties
and the seed certified seed that they
were being
and they were producing was
increasing yearly actually doubling
from year to year with the
pharmaceutical selling to
emerging seed companies uh
however after many years of this
uh growth in seed production
there still was basically no noticeable
seed being grown coming through that
pathway by the neighbors of those
pharmacy cooperatives in the areas where
those pharmaceuticals
were located which led to discussions
among the farmers
and with the breeders which led to
exploring different options for example
that of selling mini packs test packets
here just to
give a picture of the number of
certain varieties that these pharmacy
cooperatives
have produced during a four-year period
uh with uh i would like to highlight
it was the farmers themselves and their
organizations who decided
which varieties to produce on their own
risk
there was no uh contracting or uh
the breeders were only there supporting
uh
with provision of
the foundation seed as well as
accompanying with various
activities so
across three different areas a large
number of
varieties being produced and the
majority
were the new varieties of the open
pollinated
traditional type 3 4 meter height
there was a few land races that were
continually produced
but the quantity was not increasing over
time
and there were few bread of this
traditional type
the majority of varieties that they were
producing were of new types
of short and dual grain plus stover
types
and of hybrids
here just to look at
the what happened the outcomes from
the mini packs those 100 gram
seed packets that were farmers seed
co-ops were selling
for very little money but offering
farmers a chance to look at new
varieties as well as
the first chance to actually
buy to pay money to receive seed for
variety
and it was successful in terms of
farmers saving seed and even a
significant considerable number sharing
seed with others this is both for
sorghum and millet mali and
burkina faso and niger
so now we can come back to the question
can
sorghum seed be sold to farmers
and see can be sold
if uh it's for testing
in the local uh culture and
if
it benefits a group so individuals no
no go but for a farmer clock or vs
the mini packs were great for marketing
but did not generate
income uh sufficiently
but over the years the demand for larger
seat side of packages increased
uh to see co-ops currently are still
selling mostly to both buyers
but the market is unpredictable uh
at the whim of ngos government
programs on very short notice but the
farmers
are selling seed directly to the seed
co-ops are selling
directly to farmers which they realize
is a more sustainable option
many options many advantages of farmers
as the managers of seed businesses the
trust and accountability and the quality
and adaptation
so building on farmers expertise and
capacities
it's generating income where it's needed
in the rural areas
and the pharmacy co-ops can partner with
breeders for continuing to develop new
varieties
feeding the pipeline and making the seed
system sustainable
and with other belly chain actors
and the last point is breeding for
sustainable development goals
with the example of sorghum improvement
for micronutrient
nutrition in mali and the first
step is to understand the context and
here
very briefly a consumption study which
showed that
all types of nutrition aspects are
deficient but
iron across the board total
looking at feasibility for improving
ninja strata nutritional status via bio
fortification
in brief
sorghum is important especially
so children's diets are so limited
so based on uh staple cereal sorghum
millet maize but
to increase the iron content
in the flower to make a meaningful
difference in nutrition
requires a dramatic increase
in the concentration iron concentration
good news there is genetic variability
relatively low genotype by phosphorus or
environment interactions
high heritability so breeding can
contribute but only
as one component it's not enough alone
looking at the use of sorghum
by women grown by
women what's interesting to find that
thanks to a social science student
uh if a fandom
that this sorghum that women grew
was
frequently used to prepare a special
meal for the children
when they were hungry when there was no
leftovers available
which would never come from the men's
granary because that
food is for the family for the main
meals
so a pathway for child nutrition
and uh bio fortification through women
in women's sorghum cultivation
looking at processing and preparation of
the grain
here we have a whole grain in green and
manually decorticated the traditional
way
modern festival producing flower
removing the
seed coat to produce flour
and with that decortication
there's the loss of 50 percent of the
iron
also the phytate as well as zinc the
phytate content
is reduced proportionally meaning
there's no improvement or
[Music]
no change in the bioavailability of the
iron or zinc is simply
reduced through decortication
and the breeder is then incorporated
more systematically and actually
giving more attention to that trait
decortication rate
decortication losses here from the
farmer
on farm participatory variety trials
different varieties
the percent of
grain lost during decortication
of the different varieties ranging from
10 to 30 percent
l mark's land race varieties you can see
that
we have mix of improved and land race
varieties
and that there's a big difference
a much more difference than
the content of iron and zinc per se
in the grain and uh
here from unfarmed trials with
uh two hybrids uh fada
and uh sorry one hybrid fida
an nopv latta and the local variety
tablet
very similar iron concentrations in the
grain across
environments and one hybrid that was
very poor sewer with the very low
decoration yield in low iron
content so the changes made in the
breeding program
were to observe brain quality monitoring
iron and zinc concentrations
and really critically making sure that
new fridays
show it advantages when grown in
women's fields that means under low
phosphorus conditions
also typically in intercropping
conditions for example with ground nuts
the collaboration with the
breeders with food technologists
nutritionist to identify options
for improving nutrition including and
beyond
simply genetic
biofortification and
[Music]
delivering developing collaboration also
for
education it was amazing simply
in the trials talking about
nutrition about micronutrients was a new
concept
led to changes and differences in
behavior
on the part of farmers as well as
breeders
so in conclusion uh effective reading in
the center
of sorghum domestication
uh setting priorities in
building clarity of
what is targeted the product profiles if
you will
the selection strategies uh required
farmers participation with breeders
and interdisciplinary collaboration with
social scientists
gender specialists nutritionists
physiologists contributed
uh and agronomists
and that large yield
improvements are needed ten percent
uh gains uh with the complexity of
environments
and factors is cannot be noticed by
farmers it cannot
generate
any momentum if you will
but 20 30 is needed to really
make a difference but
those yield improvements must be made
with the appropriate
array of adaptation and quality
characteristics
and that farmer raider collaborative
networks
really have so much to offer in
supporting bridal diversity
ensuring experiences and resources
that the farmers and breeders bringing
together can create synergies
of the information flow and feedback
that also gender considerations and
gender inclusion is essential for
achieving benefits
for the whole family and community even
though
this is a crop that is considered to be
a men's ground
and finally the importance
to be aware and consider it to do no
harm
which can be attended to through
inclusion
of all different people and
learning together with that i'd like to
thank you
and thank the contributions of so many
many people and
also just to mention that there is
the references in full at the end for
anyone who is interested to look
further thank you
so thank you so much fred um
that was really fantastic um i
must say where we don't have a ton of
time left but
may i uh ask if anyone would like to uh
bring up any questions
uh i don't actually easily see the
hands-raised feature here
so if anybody wants to just go ahead
feel free um
hearing no open mics um let me let me
make one comment and one question fred
um i had the honor about a year ago
visiting mali and seeing one of the
participatory sorghum
trials play out and it was just a
beautiful piece of like performance art
or something
it was a hybrid that farmers were
testing and it was it was maybe their
100th
event i was told where you know you had
icresad and ngo people and
people from the community there it's
just very very impressive
um how people were able to follow a
nice protocol you know even using
digital technologies and women were able
to represent themselves very well and
decisions were made both on the agronomy
over the season that farmers had
recorded the data and also
um on the culinary test that was done on
the on that day
but i um so just that's just like a
testimonial that was really
incredible and then i i was wondering if
you could comment on the issue of g by e
of any sort like
you know the three best varieties you
mentioned came out both
on farming on station which in a way
isn't that consistent with me with the
you know the imperative of going on farm
to see
different things so ultimately do you
see what you would consider meaningful i
saw some of those lines over
you know crossing here and there but is
there anything that you would consider
meaningful g by e that you think
you know deserves note thank you
a beautiful question and
and your testimonial testimonials are
great
g by it was interesting
with analysis of the unfarm trial data
trying to tease out
major factors and it was so difficult
there are so many different factors and
they're
really interwoven what
the conclusion is is that you really
need to test
across a wide
range of environments rainfall alone
onset or ending and strike a presence
or weeding totally weed infested or not
soil fertility
all of them play a part but we couldn't
pull anything out
uh regarding on farm
combining on pharma nonstation tests
this was it's a small sample let's put
the results in perspective but
also the on station test was
uh both with uh
regular favorable conditions as well as
under managed low phosphorus conditions
which are
are approaching farmers field conditions
the productivity is
50 that of under the normal if you will
conditions uh it had higher correlation
with
unfarmed trial results higher genetic
correlations
uh heritability was not much worse
and was a really valuable
uh contribution i wouldn't say
test on lopi feels alone
it also was
risking failures
which we due to
the low fertility susceptibility to for
example rate infestation with
sort of midge etc so really combining
results from many different environments
and collaboration among breeders
among farmers uh is the way to deal with
uh g by e
um so we have a couple of comments in
the chat and then i would
unless anybody has a point to make we
can
turn fred over to the graduate students
so kathleen hefferon
has said how can the idea of gender
differences in crops and farming be
transmitted to westerners
and then ruby followed on with a comment
i second interest in that concept
as new to me personally but also as a
powerful illustration of gender
differences that can contribute to
better breeding for women's fields is
very interesting to me
and a concept i'd like to explore
further thank you so a couple people
with
clear interest in the gender issues any
anything you want to say on that
topic fred yeah um
actually i'm the wrong person about
transmitting gender
issues to westerners being that
we spent most of our time in
west africa and so it's from that
perspective that we're seeing it
and we don't have much experience trying
to talk to
westerners if you will uh
you're better at west africans sorry
sorry sorry let me take that back ava's
been doing
uh and not me
i'm showing my uh my ignorance ava
has been doing training programs but
that's not for westerners
what i was thinking is it's talking
talking talking
and learning for us
it was we were not from the beginning
engaged in any explicit gender
activities
we were interested but
we were doing what we thought was most
appropriate with the resources we had
but with learning for example that a
social science
student insisted she wanted to study
women
and women's organ production and he said
okay go ahead
and from that we learned wow
there really is a role and we do need to
take this into consideration
in our breeding program if we want to
consider the whole system
and it's the same
way for nutrition we cannot deal with
nutrition if we don't include women
i mean that was such a
big learning for us is by involving
women
yet in the culinary testing be it in the
farmer participatory
trials specifically designed for women
seed production including women in the
discussions
it changed the discussion and brought
progress that would have been missed
otherwise
okay great um so it's now 1 35 so we've
gone a bit over
and actually ellie has reminded me that
the graduate
student meeting with you fred become
starts
uh at what is for us 150
so 15 minutes from now which
will be later later for you but it's
meant to afford you
i think a chance to take a breather
between duties here
um so uh
we i guess i should thank you now unless
any if anybody wants to weigh in
please type into the chat and we'll
probably entertain your question but
otherwise fred i really want to thank
you for a beautiful seminar and for
sharing
all those that experience over um that
that career in west africa um on sorghum
i mean a lot to get a lot to value there
and i really appreciate it
so uh if you would be ready to maybe
come back to this room
in 15 minutes um catalina are you gonna
hold the room or how does that work
i have actually a link to click on for
this okay okay you're good to go okay
great
okay and never okay ellie's like
panicking there they're regular
choosing as usual okay so thank you so
much again everyone thanks for being
with us
um thanks so much fred and best wishes
for eva's
feeling better very soon okay thanks so
much
okay thank you take care right bye bye
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu